the governor of Florida is calling on a
grand jury to investigate school failure
school failures rather than the Parkland
massacre 17 students and staff members
were killed in that shooting that
Marjorie Stoneman Douglas high school
one year ago today that was one third of
the 56 school shooting deaths in 2018
making it the deadliest year on record
Adriana Diaz is in Parkland outside the
school adrian good morning on a very sad
anniversary for the people there a very
sad day indeed gale we spoke to students
and victim's parents who told us that
they are finding strength through
activism
they say the movement that emerge from
this tragedy is keeping up momentum in
fact just last week there was a group on
Capitol Hill lobbying lawmakers now
students also tell us that it's been
tough for them to balance academics and
activism and when they go to school here
they still see that building where the
massacre occurred it's a daily reminder
of what happened here especially today
do you feel safe in school absolutely
not it's just very uncomfortable being
at that particular school knowing that
that's where I nearly lost my life
Marjory Stoneman Douglas high school has
beefed up security adding more than a
hundred new cameras and doubling its
security staff to 18 but students like
senior Alea Eastman are demanding more
our lives depend on you our lives are in
your hands thank you she told her story
on Capitol Hill last week when the
gunman shot into her classroom
Nicholas Dorrit was in front of me as
Nicholas fell I matched his every
movement and hid underneath his lifeless
body in the years since the massacre
Congress passed modest legislation
allowing States and federal agencies to
better share mental health in criminal
records but no new federal gun control
laws though states including Florida
passed 66 gun control bills at least
seven states expanded background checks
and eight allowed law enforcement to
confiscate weapons from at-risk
individuals you think there's been
enough change me
absolutely not particularly for
communities of color I feel like the
conversation of gun violence prevention
has been surrounded by mass shootings or
school shootings which is only about 2%
of gun violence as a whole as students
apply pressure publicly I'm amazed that
I cannot see the end of this crowd here
in DC today
a Florida Commission investigating the
shooting made dozens of recommendations
last month including metal detectors and
so-called hard corners where students
can hide this one from inside Stoneman
Douglas is equipped with red first aid
kits with tourniquets to stop bleeding
the report also called for more funding
for the state's controversial new
Guardian program we visited a training
in June where everyday people learn to
become armed to school guards parklands
district says it's adopted more than
half of the recommendations so far that
report I think probably could have gone
further than intent Tom Hoyer lost his
15 year old son Luke in the shooting his
bedroom remains untouched it's been kind
of a hard year of firsts you know so you
go through the first birthday going
through the first family get away first
Christmas Hoyer is working with the 16
other victims families to push for more
change I would have a hard time living
myself I'd have very deep regrets if I
didn't do something that I know could be
done and this happened again
the victims families are pushing for
changes in school safety mental health
and responsible firearm ownership they
also already have more trips to
Washington planned Astra what's
happening here in parkland today there
will be no classes from Marjory Stoneman
Douglas students but they're encouraged
to volunteer there will also be a moment
of silence citywide at 221 p.m. when the
shooting began one year ago today Nora
you're thinking of all of those families
it's hard to believe that was a year ago
what little has changed Adriana thank
you